oulaï eu un problème aujourd'hui ce taux
sur ce qui est un peu d'horreur et on va
jouer immédiatement pour la meilleure
expérience recommandé de jouer avec des
écouteurs dans le noir le mec vraiment
qu'on ait peur ou alors apparemment la
librairie est hantée et voilà on y va
piteuse lapierre traduction qu'on était
sur cette chaîne youtube quoi j'ai juste
pas traduit finalement une de nuit
étoilée à ça joue au pied et elle me
prévenait commence à jouer à la fin j'en
ai marre oui la librairie c'est ça ce
lieu c'est la honte et du cul ses entés
du cul je refuse d'y aller tout
simplement on va bien regarder autour
y'a rien ça a l'air d'aller bien on va
aller dedans on va percer les secrets de
cette fameuse liban s'est fermé pourquoi
vouloir y entrer absolument comme andré
jamais ses personnages du jeu vidéo
jamais bref à l'autome à passer par la
porte de derrière
chez exane et les lieux jason bourne
c'est moi regardez je sais que là il ya
un trou dans le portail s'est levé qu'il
est venu avec un fer à souder il a fondu
les barreaux à chalumeau comme ça une
allumette comme ça ailleurs briquet que
vous allez mais qui va trop loin ok je
crois qu'on est en train de rentrer en
librairie l'actu dessus une petite
montée ça fait penser à outkast mais
l'alpha de l'alfa de l'alphabet ok on y
va oh là là on fait du parcours mon gars
on est prêt à tout pour percer le secret
la librairie c'est abusé qu'est ce qu'il
y a dans ses livres
qu'est ce qui fait qu'il est malade
alors un clic gauche pour interagir bon
à temps ou la fête au oui au journal en
tri un d'accord c'est donc cette mode
c'est juste ça mais relatant l écart
avant on était due qu elle aussi tout
est hantée du cul dans ce dans cette
maison là on est sûr à août l'as -4
voilà c'est vraiment outlast avant avant
donc là c'est quoi ça ce que j'ai
ramassé j'ai du bois de la bûchette mais
mon gars tu es mal et tableaux à quel
moment cela n'est pas hanter à toi la
vie trop de farah joie ah les filles
vous savez ce que c'est un bavoir un
monstre un jour alors journal en tri de
ok je peux cliquer pour lire [ __ ]
quelqu'un a fait tomber un livre
aujourd'hui mais pas à l'effet que
j'avais vu avant les pages de dents sont
jaunes et et crac lente je n'ai pas
reconnu le langage dans lequel était
écrit c'est du latin la langue des
démons c'est sur ce truc bête ancien il
date probablement de plusieurs siècles
n'arrive pas à déterminer exactement ce
que c'est il n'a aucune photo excepté
parfois celle d'un diagramme et la
couverture est juste plein de noirs
je vais devoir faire quelques recherches
c'est un livre très intéressant je ne
sais pas qui l'a laissée ici mais il est
venu au bon endroit
ok d'accord donc le 2 c'est quoi c'est
pas beaucoup dormi la nuit dernière de
plus en plus dur de traverser cette
librairie n'a pas de penser à ce livre
je n'ai aucune idée de dans quel en
dégage il est écrit mais je crois que la
lettre commence à prendre sens c'est
très étrange
il essaye de me dire quelque chose me
concentrer là-dessus m'aide à me sentir
mieux
donc je vais lire à travers ce livre
encore et encore et si le déchiffrer
n'en fait pas sa salive renty du cul
[ __ ] tout à dom pourquoi quand je
marche je pète pourquoi tous ces ouvert
mon gars s'était pas ouvert du tout un
fauteur de livres se lire les seuls déjà
pas le dire pour que tu arrêtes de lire
ce livre voilà comme disait madame
madeleine en cm2 à angres de français en
touche est un truc baptisée easy c'est
quoi ça une clé hockey à toi je veux
porter cette part de quoi avec arme en
amont ce qui est passé de l'autre côté
je me chie dessus
à ne pas confondre avec ju jitsu l'art
martial vous avez un ce qu'on ne
pratique pas du tout d'ailleurs se voir
et je suis terrifiée je t'ai [ __ ]
c'est dingue ce qui est pourtant il n'a
rien de terrifiant mais les brumes ont
mis tellement mal personne n'y a
personne ont fermé hier nous on est bien
on est bien on est bien en ont pas leur
loge de grand mère nous arrêtent de pire
au deuil qui paie depuis le moment où je
peux en plus c'est génial c'est
totalement synchro non stop non non non
il veut pas prendre la note c'est bon il
a pris quelqu'un est venu à la librairie
aujourd'hui ils ont essayé de voler ce
livre à méplat de votre souris vivantes
et on a récupéré livré avons remis dans
son étagère c'est notre librairie
tous les livres sont à nous c'est plus
en plus dur d'écrire et de lire le livre
m'a dit que je n'avais plus besoin de
tenir un journal intime
je pense que c'est vrai j'ai juste
besoin de ce livre je dois continuer mes
recherches d'accord donc le mec tourne
totalement dans la folie du livre quoi
abusé n'a pas de portée mais on va
remonter on va se faire couper la gorge
par un fantôme
on n'empêche on a une clé une bouchard
fera oublier un la bûche et pour exposer
le crâne du fantôme qu'on le verra à
tancer cholin ok moi dans cette porte
d'accord donc toutes les bougies cette
année on a eu une elle commençait dans
norme elle arrive toujours à lire le
livre donc tout va bien mais ça se fait
plutôt voté complet de popstars et
bordel moi-même dans cette pièce il ya
une bougie qui c'est a alors je vois
encore mais kaka à jour chaque phare est
le poteau mais tout va bien à l'eau au
oui mais voilà les bûches
alors du coup regarder la librairie
s'est ouverte et c'est un véritable
passage secret auquel on assiste
actuellement dans incroyables et toiles
d'araignées ce secret ça à mon dieu on
va tomber sur la région du seigneur des
anneaux
tu vas nous couper en deux voies se
pourrait que frodon dans une toile
atteint c'est quoi cette fumée noire la
non mais stop
il ya des gens qui fument de la drogue
là moi je veux pas y aller moi je suis
un flic en civil ainsi je vois que les
arrêts direct à mende
la position foetale vaincra
celle qui impose son style alors ce
livre m'appelle c'est ça le fameux livre
aussi s'affaiblir dont elle parle je lai
ça y est j'ai le livre est tous les
fantômes de la planète à mes trousses ou
doit jamais mais a pu à la salopette tu
n'auras jamais vieille femme aigrie et
fripés c'est parti ici j'approche dumas
un coup de jus l'échelle d'échelle
l'échelle les chaînes l'échelle
l'échelle non c'est pas ça
a à peine fait quoi avec je sais il faut
se mettre debout sur ce pilier dans
c'est un petit peu ma main puis c'est
que si tu sois en regardant le fronton
de résultats mais comment je fais ah bah
voilà tout simplement allez ciao femme
celle où je retourne la porte qui est de
l'autre côté entre elles pas eu
j'ai la clé non non quoi mais c'est au
web ça je veux plus jamais approché de
la pop qu'elle abat d'accord à mon avis
avec la tri dans la librairie [ __ ] le
palais avait pas pourquoi elle attend tu
attends quoi je veux plus revenir en
arrière en fait c'est ça je crois qu'il
ya un mur invisible entre elle et moi
elle peut pas venir c'est humiliant
grand-mère ou pas quoi pourquoi pourquoi
je me baladais pour chercher une clé ou
un truc que attend l'agression gratuite
bah c'est quoi je change de jeu oh
wen maintenant sur the night spx et vous
allez voir on va rester dans le doigt
d'honneur wahou graphiquement c'est
incroyable c'est du unreal engine 18
attention particularité du jeu le jeu
vulgaire auj
calmez-vous la calmez-vous tout ça elle
a toujours su quoi faire elle n'a jamais
besoin d'écouté qui que ce soit mais
cette ombre elle parle tu dois écouter
moi j'écoute majeur fait des doigts
c'est plus ça marche mieux et plus
radicale non mais c'est vrai on peut le
dire a été braves est déterminée à temps
cl je fais un doigt bon bah écoutez je
vois qu'on a fait le tour du jeu c'est
passionnant faire des doux en fantôme
j'adore au revoir avant les gens se dire
qu'on est sûr c'est que je perds ça vous
a plu c'est le cas de tpm m dos comme
d'habitude je suit avec pour seul abri
je pensais qu'ils avaient une solution
un tweet mais la grand mère m'a tuer
autant vous dire que je préfère
largement les grands-mères qu'on a nous
qui nous font des bons petits plats
délicieux on attend 10 passes à toutes
les sauces un truc bah voilà ben voilà
on aimerait bien savoir garder on s'est
entraînés dans une prochaine vidéo par 2
ou bien chaude pisse